madame
madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
chers
ces deux motions sont sûrs déposées par
nos collègues de la nupesse et du
rassemblement national était attendu
nous le savions tous puisqu'ils avaient
déclaré avant même de connaître la
nature du projet de loi de finances
qu'il vaut très concret nos collègues
républicains également
entendre ce que j'ai entendu à droite et
à gauche chacun assumera ses volts
alternatif ou cumulatif
l'engagement de la responsabilité du
Gouvernement sur ces textes et donc la
suite logique il ne faut pas mes chers
collègues fermines de son étonné ou
comme l'a dit ma collègue Mathilde Bano
affirmait que cette méthode était une
brutalité et collègue Chassaigne aussi
non ce sont juste les institutions et
l'équilibre que leur auteur ont su
trouver je voudrais simplement rappeler
ici ce que disait Michel Debré le 27
août 1958 devant le Conseil d'État qui
expliquait les raisons de la Linéa 3 de
l'article 49 de la Constitution
l'expérience a conduit à prévoir en
outre une disposition quelque peu
exceptionnelle pour assurer malgré les
manœuvres le vote d'un texte
indispensable les Français le savent
aucun État ne peut vivre sans un budget
qui au-delà du paiement des salaires des
fonctionnaires détermine une politique
et les moyens sa mise en œuvre
nous avons eu le temps ces dernières
semaines de discuter en commission
commençants pendant des dizaines
d'heures de cette première partie du PLF
dans une ambiance tantôt animée tantôt
plus calme mais avec toujours une
volonté partagée d'entrer dans le fond
des sujets en commission nous avons nous
sommes longuement entretenus sur la
suppression la CVAE sur l'évolution du
crédit pour recherche sur la fiscalité
environnementale ou encore sur le
soutien que nous devons offrir aux
collectivités face à la hausse des prix
de l'énergie je voudrais remercier le
président de la commission des finances
Éric Coquerel le rapporteur général
Jean-René Cazeneuve et mes collègues
pour la bonne tenue des débats nous
étions souvent loin d'être d'accord mais
nous avons débattu en séance nous avons
eu aussi de longs débats sur l'impôt sur
le revenu sur l'imposition l'immobilier
celle des agriculteurs ou encore la
fiscalité des successions sujets qui a
suscité sur tous les bancs de l'intérêt
et sur le lequel nous ne pourrons nous
exonérer centrer d'esprit d'une
réflexion dans les prochains mois les
députés démocrates avaient au début de
l'examen de ce texte dressait un
ensemble de priorités avec en
particulier la proposition d'une réforme
d'ampleur de la fiscalité du logement
notamment en zone tendue sujet qui
intéresse nombre des bancs de notre
assemblée et sur lesquels nous
réussissons régulièrement à construire
des ponts avec la droite comme avec la
gauche la fiscalité immobilière est
notamment la taxation des revenus
fonciers et des plus-values immobilières
auraient besoin d'un grand toilettage
nous sommes en droit de nous interroger
lorsqu’un contribuable propriétaire d'un
bien acquis depuis plus de 30 ans
immeuble ne constituant pas sa résidence
principale en Corse autour des lacs ou
encore sur la côte atlantique dans la
pris a pu être multiplié par 6 voire 12
depuis l'acquisition soit entièrement
exonérées d'impôts sur la plus-value
réalisée à la session
un juste retour alors d'une partie des
recettes fiscales sur les territoires
concernés seraient à étudier un peu à la
lumière des droits de mutation à titre
onéreux
nous nous saluons bien sûr la révision
du zonage de la taxe sur les logements
vacants et la taxe d'habitation sur la
résidence secondaire mais cette mesure
nous semble un peu trop timide madame la
Première ministre il faut que nous
saisissions le sujet de manière plus
systémique
et vous savez que les députés démocrates
sont à vos côtés pour y travailler les
députés démocrates avaient aussi pour
objectif de faciliter la vie des
entreprises des petites entreprises de
notre pays et proposer un ensemble
d'amendements dans ce but plusieurs de
nos collègues sur les bancs étaient
missiles en premier lieu Véronique ovagy
nous rejoint dans ses constats et dans
ses propres propositions et je regrette
nous n'ayons pas réussi à convaincre
davantage de nos collègues ainsi que le
gouvernement nous pouvons toutefois
retenir plusieurs motifs de satisfaction
en premier lieu le praticien que je suis
se réjouit la précision du régime fiscal
doit transmission des entreprises
individuelles ayant obtenu l'impôt
société mais je crois que nous devons
continuer à accompagner fiscalement la
belle réforme du 22 février 2022 en
faveur de l'activité professionnelle
indépendante
de la même manière nous sommes ravis
d'avoir pu convaincre le gouvernement de
l'opportunité de relever même légèrement
le plafond du taux réduit d'impôt sur
les sociétés pour les PME à 42 500 euros
ce relèvement permettra à nos PME
d'avoir plus de bénéfices pour investir
et pour se développer
élu un peu partout de France et de
Navarre les députés démocrates attachent
une grande importance à la situation de
nos agriculteurs qui font face tant à de
très fortes tensions conjoncturelle mais
aussi à des défis plus structurels
notamment sur l'accès aux fonciers nous
souhaitons compter aux côtés de notre
ministre Marc féno défend des renouveler
le modèle agricole français avec
l'indexation sur l'inflation de la
déduction pour épargne de précautions
créées en 2019 par exemple ou encore en
prolongeant d'un an le crédit d'impôt
haut de valeur environnementale
l'assemblée a également adopté un autre
initiative et celle de nos collègues de
la majorité une hausse du plafond
l'exonération de 75% des droits de
mutation à titre gratuit des bienfaisant
l'objet d'un bail à long terme cette
hausse doit aider les agriculteurs à
mieux transmettre leur terre à leur
famille plutôt que de devoir les céder à
des sociétés parfois étrangères qui font
monter le prix du foncier
jusqu'à interroger notre souveraineté
alimentaire nous serons à vos côtés aux
côtés du ministre de l'Agriculture pour
écrire un futur loi d'orientation et
d'avenir agricole annoncé par le
président de la République nous sommes
aussi satisfaits d'avoir en conjonction
avec nos partenaires de la majorité mis
en place un filet de sécurité pour
toutes les collectivités qui se
trouvaient fragilisées par la hausse des
prix de l'énergie à ce dispositif
s'ajoute une hausse exceptionnelle de
320 millions d'euros de la DGF force et
de reconnaître que notre majorité
présidentielle accompagne bien nos
collectivités en ces temps troublées en
fait à travers ce budget et ceux qui
suivront cette législature avec votre
gouvernement madame la Première ministre
nous voulons défendre deux axes tout
d'abord protéger les Français garantir
leur avenir le préparer les rassurer
aussi pour qu'il retrouve une forme de
confiance qui depuis longtemps
maintenant s'étioles il demande à juste
titre que la protection de l'État dans
ces multiples crises que nous traversons
après la guerre en Ukraine chez nous en
Europe la crise énergétique l'inflation
ils attendent nous semble-t-il des
signaux clairs une solidarité à
l'égarder plus faible une bienveillance
pour les aider à avancer un soutien une
liberté aussi celle d'entreprendre celle
qui permet l'émergence de tous les
talons celle de vivre de leur travail la
liberté que les émanciperas et offrant
des citoyens actifs dans la société en
second lieu ce que nous cherchons à
construire c'est un pays souverain
c'est-à-dire un pays qui garantit sa
liberté souveraineté alimentaire
souveraineté énergétique souveraineté
économique un pays qui attire également
les talents les capitaux les entreprises
celles qui créent les emplois et de la
richesse pour assurer la solidarité
c'est peut-être là madame la Première
ministre monsieur le ministre de
l'économie que nous aimerions avancer
davantage pour nous le taux de
prélèvement obligatoire ne peut être
l'alpha et l'oméga de notre politique
certes nous sommes le pays qui a l'un
des plus forts taux de prélèvement
d'Europe et oui toute la politique menée
depuis 5 ans vise à redonner de l'air à
nos entreprises à envoyer des signaux au
monde entier pour redevenir enfin
attractif et ça marche nous envoyons les
résultats c'est pourquoi nous avons
refusé la semaine dernière le retour de
l'ISF ou de tout autre taxe sur la
transmission d'entreprise qui ont leur
temps avaient fait fuir les capitaux et
les investisseurs nous croyons en
entreprise privée qui est une des
garantie de liberté publique mais
également l'économie mixte qui est dans
certains cas indispensables et
performantes mais nous devons aussi
rester attractif par parce que nous
agissons sur d'autres leviers l'école la
santé l'aide au plus diminue et tout ce
qui fait qu'un état solidaire un pays
apaisé est aussi un pays attractif il
existe également le monde associatif
avec la cohorte de nos concitoyens si
généreux qui méritent d'être accompagné
pour le groupe démocrate une réflexion
sur tous nos bancs devrait nous mener à
légiférer pour une plus grande
solidarité et notamment fiscale sans
pour autant briser les talons oui une
réforme fiscale non vergure adaptée au
temps que nous vivons prenant en compte
des évolutions sociétales les évolutions
du monde seraient nécessaires je vous
propose monsieur le ministre de
l'Économie monsieur le ministre du
Budget de y atteler avec vous une
économie florissante dans un pays dans
les mots pourraient ranger la cohésion
sociale ou qui s'ouvre d'une démocratie
affaiblie requiert des réponses nous
nous l'avons vu ces dernières semaines
les blocages peuvent être soudains et
mettre le pays en position de faiblesse
et c'est pour cela que le groupe
démocrate considère qu'un pays qui va
bien est un pays qui a des entreprises
compétitives mais pas seulement
la France de 2022 n'est pas celle de
2017 les changements du monde sont une
évidence non seulement le changement
climatique mais l'environnement
international la guerre qui se rapproche
ainsi je crois que nous devons avoir le
courage de nous poser les bonnes
questions le sens de l'amendement que
nous avons déposé sur les super
dividendes n'avait pas pour but de
chambouler tous les équilibres de la
trajectoire définie par la président de
la République et toutes les mesures qui
ont été prises depuis plusieurs années
il avait pour but de se dire que dans un
contexte particulier on peut changer de
temporairement quelques règles en
demandant une contribution
exceptionnelle à ceux qui ont des
bénéfices supplémentaires
il avait il avait pour but de dire à
certains entreprises de grande taille
rétribuez vos actionnaires mais
n'oubliez pas les salariés ni l'avenir
de l'entreprise et de la planète avec
des investissements en forme
j'ai pu vous le dire je regrette que
c'est amendement qui a été voté avec une
large majorité n'est pas poursuit son
chemin même s'il n'était pas parfait et
la navette aurait pu l'améliorer
et comme vous le savez et comme vous le
savez nous sommes très favorables au
partage de la richesse dans les
entreprises un engagement fort de notre
président de la République même si je
reconnais que les deux amendements
visant à la transposition des décisions
européennes concernant la contribution
exceptionnelle des
artificiels je vais y arriver sont une
très bonne réponse à l'échelle
européenne et j'en viens aussi à mon
dernier point celui de la méthode ce que
nous venons de vivre n'est pas
compréhensible par nos concitoyens vous
pouvez les uns et les autres penser que
s'opposer pour des oppositions et le
principal sujet nous considérons nous au
groupe démocrate que nous devons savoir
nous écouter et parfois douter car sans
doute il n'y a pas d'écoute
cela ne veut pas dire être toujours
d'accord mais essayez d'être constructif
et de pas rester sur des postures de
départ nous pouvons et c'est même être
devoir devant ce pays qui est en
difficulté dialoguer construire et agir
autant que possible les Français
attendent que nous réglions leurs
problèmes et que nous leur donnions les
moyens d'avancer si chaque arrêtent dans
sa posture politiqueienne cela ne peut
satisfaire personne et surtout cela ne
fera que desservir notre République et
son fonctionnement démocratique de même
que la stabilité de l'Europe que nous
construisons depuis plus de 60 ans n'est
jamais acquise et reste un combat de
tous les jours de la même façon notre
démocratie sera jamais assez solide pour
que l'on sente désintéresse mais pour
elle aussi nous devons nous battre bien
sûr madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
ne voterons pas ces motion bien au
contraire nous serons vos soutiens dans
un esprit ouvert et constructif celui
qui laisse une place déterminante au
dialogue à l'écoute pour l'ensemble
construire des solutions au service des
Français je vous remercie je vous